>> My name's Don Tapscott, and I'm a member
of the Global Attending
Council on the Future of Government.
And I've just received the -- the Youth Task
Force report of the Global
Redesign Initiative.
And I think it's a great piece of work.
And it's so important that young people are
involved because around the
world we have the biggest generation ever,
and this is a generation
that is very different.
They're enormously influential.
A lot of them are wired, they learn and think
differently, and at their
fingertips they have the most powerful tool
ever for figuring out
what's going on, for informing others, even
for organizing collective
responses.
And the problems that -- that the Global Redesign
Initiative is
addressing are ultimately not going to be
resolved by my generation.
These problems are going to be handed over
to young people, to you.
And the world is not a very happy place right
now.
So we're counting on you to really bring about
the kind of changes
necessary to ensure that the smaller world
that your kids inherit will
be a better one.
So get involved and keep up the great work.